Because access to the singleton is through a class, and
class names are normally known globally, singletons somehow,
sometimes act like global state instead of the traditional owned instances that
we see in other uses of, of classes in object-oriented languages.
We can also run into trouble in situations where the clients are multithreaded.
That is, several threads may be trying to create that
single instance at one time.
Leading to the production of multiple singletons.
Question arises as to when you create the single instance.
One strategy is to do it at startup.
Which you could think of as eager construction.
Or do you wait until the first use to, to create it,
which could be called lazy construction.
Then some issues with respect to what it actually means to be a singleton.
Does singleton a word mean at most once or exactly once?
Similarly, does singleton mean only one ever or only one at a time?
In languages with destructors, like C++, you could get rid of the instance and
then later create another instance of that same singleton
without violating the rule that there's at most one such instance.